Good.
We're rolling
some of the major events in human history,
our population level
consequences of individual
decisions and one that has great
impact on the issue of mismatch and of
the health of contemporary populations is
the great transition.
That is the phrase we use to describe
the combination of the industrial
revolution and the epidemiological
transition that followed from it
that lead to declines in mortality,
fertility that are changing selection.
The effects of change selection,
uh,
are particularly noticeable
in life history evolution.
They have led to increase longevity and
the exposure of antagonistic pleiotropy.
The increased longevity is not necessarily
the product of selection and can
simply be the product of decreased
mortality rates resulting from these
transitions.
There've been associated impacts on
nutrition energetics and fertility,
and at the same time,
there's been a major shift from
infectious to degenerative disease.
This is one of the most remarkable
recent experiences in human history with
impact on medical issues.
It is probably the largest single
change in human populations since the
invention of agriculture and it
combines changes in three areas,
labor, technology, and
economics. In that context,
we refer to it as the industrial
revolution and birth and death rates,
age distributions, nutrition
and growth. In that context,
we refer to it as the demographic
transition and in disease prevalence from
infectious disease and
malnutrition to cancer,
chronic disease and degenerative disease.
In that context,
we refer to it as the
epidemiological transition.
So these processes are continuing.
They have not yet gone to completion.
They are massively rearranging
the human ecology of the planet.
Yeah.
Here is a diagram that shows you what's
going on with mortality and fertility.
These are births per female per lifetime.
This is life expectancy at birth.
In this panel, which is pretty
much pre-transition, you see India,
about 1900 Sweden about 1775
England about 1750 France,
about 1740 and in this panel over
here you see post-transition,
Hungary, Sweden, and France.
So you can see that the births per female
per lifetime has dropped from about
six down to less than two.
And you can see that life at birth has
increased from somewhere between 25 and
40 years up to 75 to 80 years.
That's a huge shift.
Okay.
Across this transition,
the driver of selection on humans
shifted for mortality to fertility.
In this diagram we have births
per female per lifetime.
That's the total fertility rate. Here
we also are plotting on the same graph,
the mortality rate per thousand.
This is the mortality rate here and
we are plotting selection intensities.
This is the total potential selection
intensity caused by variation in both
mortality and fertility rates and it
can be broken down into the mortality
component and the fertility component.
The timescale runs from 1540 up to
1991 and the sample is from England.
So what we can see here is that
total selection has declined.
Mortality Selection has declined
virtually dizzyhero but selection due to
variation in fertility actually has
continued and it is what is maintaining
selection and contemporary populations.
This steep decline here in fertility rate,
the slightly less steep
decline in mortality rate is
what is usually called the
demographic transition.
And if we take the decline in
fertility rate as the marker,
then it says the demographic transition
was pretty much completed in the UK by
about the about the year 1900
the transition has major effects on
human evolution in some post transition
populations. For example, the
US, Australia and Finland,
researchers found that both men and women
are experiencing selection for earlier
age.
At first birth women in the u s are
experiencing selection for greater age at
last birth and at menopause,
greater weight and shorter height and
there was selection for lower levels of
cholesterol and systolic blood pressure
and other populations.
In this case The Gambia,
the results differed selection shifted
from decreasing hide and increasing body
mass index to increasing
height and decreasing body
mass index as the population
moved through the demographic transition
in this case that occurred about 1975
in one population in Denmark,
the genetic influences on early fertility
increased strongly so they were being
exposed by changes in
nutrition and technology.
What this means is that in
post transitional societies,
the reproductive window in humans is
broadening the combination of earlier age
at first birth and later age at last
birth is broadening that window.
This may not be surprising
because selection is
increasingly driven by variation
in fertility and therefore it's
affecting traits that are associated with
fertility is also increasing the intensity
of the conflict between biology and
culture.
For in some of these cultures there is
pressure to start having children later
in life and to have fewer of them,
particularly in two career families where
many women would like to delay their
first child until
they're in their thirties
another
issue that arises with the transition is
that the increased lifespan is exposing
genes that have antagonistic pleiotropic
effects the longer post reproductive
lifespans of these
post-transition populations or
showing us that we had previously
accumulated quite a bit of effect of
antagonistic pleiotropy.
So those are genes that
benefit reproduction early
in life but have negative
effects late in life.
Genetic analyses of cancer
risk in dementia suggested
advantages and fertility
or juvenile survival are linked to the
risks of these diseases in old age,
and these links have been suggested for
genes associated with breast cancer,
with cancer in general and with dementia.
The growing global burden of degenerative
disease is explained in part by the
exposure of previously evolved
and previously hidden costs.
So these are some of the vulnerabilities
that the evolution of aging has built
into our genome and they are now being
exposed by a mismatch to a completely new
kind of environment.
Yeah.
They're also impacts on nutrition,
energetics and fertility.
The average person in 1800 was not much
better off nutritionally than an average
person thousands of years earlier.
The great transition
uncoupled cycles of mortality,
infertility from the price of grain
between 1961 and 2003 there was a 25%
global increase in energy consumption.
That's about 550 kilocalories
per person per day.
The plastic biological response to
improve nutrition and growth was earlier.
Men are shorter time to conception,
less risk of miscarriage
and leader menopause.
Simultaneous changes in culture including
contraception and the cost of raising
children postpone childbearing and
decreased lifetime reproductive success.
Concurrent with these nutritional
changes and demographic changes,
there has been a big shift from
infectious to noncommunicative disease.
I've shown this figure before.
It deserves emphasis.
During the last half of the 20th century,
the incidence of diseases like rheumatic
fever, hepatitis, a, measles, mumps,
and tuberculosis declined strikingly
the incidence of immune disorders.
This is in the United States.
Incidents of immune disorders
climbed considerably,
so this increase also
was found for cancer,
cardiovascular disease,
obesity, diabetes and dementia.
So there's been a huge shift in the post
transitional societies and the kinds of
diseases that medicine has to deal with.
We can see this is a
striking example of mismatch.
It's really the most recent contribution
of environmental change to mismatch
disease.
The shifts in selection pressures
also measure the degree of mismatch.
So in the mismatch lectures we saw
that when we find mismatch it means the
natural selection is operating.
Yeah.
The causes in this case are largely
cultural and are mediated by economics and
technology.
Some of the consequences are biological,
mismatched diseases and
shifts in selection pressures.
Yeah.
So to summarize, improvements
in the quality, quantity,
and reliability of food
supply and reduction in child
mortality from infections
is infectious.
Disease are sharply changing,
both phenotypic plastic end genetic
evolved responses in humans.
These changed responses include shifts
in metabolic resource allocation and
disease resistance, as well as
increases in allergy, asthma,
and autoimmune diseases.
The mismatch diseases,
okay.
Extensions to the lifespan or revealing
previously hidden costs of reproduction
that are now expressed lead in life is
increased risk of degenerative disease.
Navigating issues like this in which
biological and cultural evolution are
interacting to change.
Health and disease requires facility
in moving between the interests of
individuals and the
interest of populations.
Understanding evolutionary processes
helps to develop that facility and that
mental agility.